[Music]
the sound of
trickling water might seem harmless
even peaceful but in the polar
regions this sound is a sinister warning
of an event that could swallow up the
arctic landscape
what would happen to the climate why
couldn't you eat fish anymore
and how much carbon is stored in the
arctic
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the arctic
turned into a mega slump
[Music]
we've really done it now we ignored all
the warnings
we ignored science we thought we had
more time but now
the permafrost in the arctic is melting
at an abrupt thaw
which means it's happening fast
as it melts this formerly frozen layer
of undecayed plant debris
will release a massive amount of carbon
into the atmosphere
and now because of all that carbon
our time is up
permafrost covers an area about twice
the size of the united states
it's created when tundra plants like
grasses and mosses
die instead of decaying and releasing
organic carbon the plant matter is
frozen
into a layer of soil trapping the carbon
dioxide and methane
that would have been released
if this important layer in the arctic
disintegrates
it would be catastrophic
as permafrost melts the ice buried
beneath the soil
also melts the draining water carries
heat
spreading the dangerous thawing
[Music]
tunnels and air pockets are created and
the ground
sinks into the newly empty caverns below
melt water and rain fill the dents
expanding them
into lakes if hundreds of these happened
at the same time
they could merge this would create
one giant mega slump where the arctic
landscape used to be
the more than 13 million people who live
in the arctic would have to flee
immediately
[Music]
1500 billion tons of carbon would be
released into the atmosphere
that's three times the amount stored in
the planet's forest
this is bad enough but unfortunately
we're now in a positive climate feedback
loop
the melting ice only increases the
amount of heat the earth's surface
absorbs which
then melts more ice
[Music]
and this warms the planet
[Music]
since the industrial revolution humans
have been releasing
increasing amounts of carbon into the
atmosphere
and the positive feedback loop amplifies
that effect
as the ice melts the sea levels will
rise
wiping out whole coastal cities and even
if you don't live
in the arctic or on the coast you'd
still have a lot to worry about
climate change would come fast and
fiercely
droughts would dry up some places while
others would face an
increase in precipitation storms would
rip
through the cities that are left and
mercury from the melted permafrost would
enter the oceans
wetlands and food systems
you wouldn't be able to eat fish anymore
because they would have such high levels
of this dangerous chemical
and the arctic mega slump would never
stop
growing more and more of the earth's
ground would become
unstable
[Music]
forcing people to flee south to higher
ground
according to the 2018 arctic report card
the spanish flu smallpox and the plague
could still be held in permafrost layers
with the permafrost melted these
diseases would be released
and would spread rapidly among densely
packed cities
like i said in the beginning if the
permafrost melts
our time is up in reality
mega slumps don't form overnight but
while you might not wake up to one
new giant mega slump they are happening
the largest slump is in batagay in
siberia
it's known as the gateway to the
underworld
it measures more than 900 meters wide
and
it's continuing to expand
and since the arctic's temperatures have
increased
twice as fast as the global average
these slumps are more likely to happen
[Music]
what can we do to stop more mega slumps
from forming
well our best option is to limit the
amount of greenhouse gas released into
the atmosphere
while capturing carbon dioxide
if we fail to do this then
we'd better find a way to re-freeze the
arctic
before it's too late
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you